[Music]
one strong killer apps well do this for
weeks
challenge and get yourself ready for the
summer season this workout is a puddle
friendly we will not be doing any
jumping and you can do it no matter what
fitness level you're at
so for best results combined this
workout together with total body
strength and also cardio workouts and I
challenge you to end your workout for
the next four weeks with this challenge
less talking and let's get straight into
the workout so each exercise will be for
45 seconds long with 15 seconds rest in
between there will be two separate
circuits to really target those core
muscles for the first circuit what
you'll need is one really light weight
I'm using three kilos or use anything
you can grab from your home okay let's
get into it so the first workout is
squat with a shoulder press okay
so I want you to keep your knees and
your toes pointed forward and I wanted
to bring them close together so not too
wide and I want to give me a deep squat
elbows touch your knees and push it back
up okay by giving me a deep squat you're
engaging your core muscles all right so
remember guys squat it's not just
working on your legs but it is also
working on your core as you straighten
your body push up with the heels squeeze
your butt and squeeze your core all
right so doing abs work on it's not all
about crunches okay in fact we will not
be doing any traditional crunches so
push up squat deep and tighten your core
and push up very good rest next workout
is going to be a static lunge with a
twist
okay so let's work on one side to begin
with and for the second set we will work
on the opposite side
so step lunch and just twist just one
side good this will work on the obliques
so static lunge and
Chris all right in order to keep
yourself static you have to engage your
core
good work on those deep core muscles
clip back twist pull it back tuck your
tummy in feel your legs burning feel
your core muscles burning and keep
twisting and look the opposite side good
keep going twist one side forward twist
forward twist and forward good five more
seconds keep twisting I know your legs
should be on the fire and your car good
next workout Wood chop okay so stand
slightly wider toes pointed forward
bring your weights up to the right and
twist it and imagine you're chopping
wood and up the opposite side and twist
it okay so up chop up the opposite side
and twist good again this will work on
the obliques twist bring your knee close
to the mat and up twist up and twist
good
pull it feel your obliques and twist
very nice
keep going you should also feel your
heart rate increasing and you will be
burning calories keep twisting opposite
left to right left to right good few
more keep going five more seconds don't
stop right now and we want to move on to
the first workout rest for 15 seconds
let's not stop now let's get straight
into squat with show the press so
slightly narrow squat okay toes pointed
forward just be a nice deep squat ready
reach up
squat down tap and up good elbows to
your knees push your butt back tap
and crucial very good extend your arms
squeeze your butt squeeze your core and
push all the way up nice keep going good
look straight ahead breathe in and
breathe out
you're almost there and remember the
next workout is a static lunge and we
want to work on the opposite side okay
it's a switch side five more seconds
push squeeze your core type in and get
now left leg forward okay all right leg
forward depending on which leg you're
done step back all right
and I want you to give me the opposite
twist very good ready let's go
twist nice and control sometimes small
movements means more muscles being
worked upon good field your left oblique
being worked on good small movement
balance yourself breathe in control nice
controlled movement good keep going keep
twisting very nice you're halfway there
more than halfway there whoa I can feel
my legs burning but do not stop now okay
twist good steady twist few more twists
keep going twist give me one more and
rest it out good job
all right stand slightly wider right now
toes point it out and remember opposite
side reach the opposite side all right
so start on your right and twist and
chop to your life good up then good up
and twist up and twist very good bend
your knees twist push the strength down
into the floor and bring it back up and
twist good do the side of your obliques
working if you feel that you want to
push yourself even more what you can do
is lift heavier as you progress through
the weeks all right
no jumping at all but this will really
work on your core and I said get you
sweating last one more and good well
done
no take a one-minute break keep yourself
hydrated drink some water because we
want to move on to the second circuit so
cubistic hydrated seconds again coming
up to work more on your core
[Music]
keep your heart rate up we're moving on
to the second circuit this circuit is
based on repetitions so each workout
will have different ition the first
workout will be a plank walk with
spider-man
alright so watch me we're gonna start
with one spider-man left and right
use your mat walk all the way to the end
of the mat and right at the end let's do
two spider-man's okay so bring your
knees towards your elbow and now walk
back right to the end of your mat let's
go 3 spider-man's good one - bend your
knee elbows slightly 3 good now let's
walk back alright
small movement control keep your body
flat let's go for for spider-man 2 3 4
good walk back give me one last one
which will be 5
spider-man's 1 2 alternate knees 2 which
elbow 3 4 and 1 last one 5 and good now
let's move on to the second workout
which will be single lake mountain
climber nice and control okay so let's
just start on your left leg so up bring
your leg in crunch push it back squeeze
your butt in - so we want to do 10
repetitions good three lines and control
no rushing for crunch
push it back five good see your sweat
dripping 6
push seven push nice and control eight
don't rush a workout
nine last one tan in and push good now
just lie down on your mat the third
workout will be alternate crunches okay
so all I want you to do is bring both
legs up 90 degrees 1 lik down crunch in
and alternate good good let's go to 3
rich for rich by rich 6 good let's aim
for Chow 7 8
keep going don't stop now 9 10 last tube
1 reach 2 and change very good
back up let's move on to the first
workout which is a walking plank with
spider-man all right
you know the work on give me your best
effort and remember controlled movements
ok let's go
give me one spider-man go one and now
let's walk to the end
give me two one and two good nice and
control feel your abs your obliques
every part of your call working 3 1 2
three nice my sweat is dripping it's
like raining right now give me four one
two three one more four and now let's
walk it back okay as much as you can to
keep your body flat let's go last five
one two I can feel your print okay don't
stop right now three four last one five
rested on a little bit let's not stop
right now let's get on to mountain
climber the other side okay right good
let's get back up into play let's work
on your right side now control one push
to push three in push for nice keep
going tuck it in five six seven eight
[Music]
control nine if your body is shaking
that's a good sign ten all right sweetie
one last workout let's go down onto the
mat this is real guys I am not stopping
you at all so legs up 90 degrees let's
give our child one reach good crunch and
feel low apps as you bring a leg down
for your upper abs as you crunch up
that's three now good keep going for
nice and controlled licks 90 degrees
five very good six keep going
seven point your toes reach up eight
look up last four more nine
ten through your abs tightening and
burning plus two more one last one - and
now relax and just stretch it out but
that's your four week killer app
challenge stretch it out a little bit
okay stretch it out whoo so that's your
four week killer apps challenge remember
that by doing one thousand crunches you
will not grow your apps or have a flat
tummy
for best results again combine this
workout with total body strength and
also cardio exercises you can check them
out in the links below as well tag your
friends share this video with your
friends and challenge them to this
workouts like this video and subscribe
to my youtube channel
turn on your notification button so that
you will get notified every time I share
a new workout video recipes and also
fitness tips all the best